a virtual workshop about the daca  program happened this afternoon  casa del migrante hosted the online  forum which was completely free  the purpose was to help guide eligible  candidates to complete  the requirements for the obama era  federal program which protects  young undocumented immigrants from  deportation at the end of the day you  know it's it's a two-year permit that  they're getting  and like you said timelines are crucial  that's why we try to push everyone to do  it now that we have it open  we don't know what's going to happen now  but take advantage of it  well the local organization says they  have received over 100 new applications  for the program  interests sparked after immigration  officials approved more than 170  applications  across the country the program was at a  standstill after president trump tried  to terminate it  but a u.s supreme court ruling prevented  it the next workshop is on wednesday at  10 in the morning  visit 8newsnow.com for details